why do you think Pokemon go is so
popular right now as opposed to other
games I think Pokemon goes like a
perfect match of Technology and a
franchise that's been around for a
couple decades there's this player base
that's enjoyed Pokemon and variety of
iterations there's a lot of miss fellows
are the come back to the bunch it's
great those like game like whenever you
were really young this was what you play
like Game Boy this is all I watched on
TV not while I watch them to this is
although I 17 I played so many people
from probably my generation forward grew
up playing pokemon right and so there
have been games like Pokemon before so
you might have heard of like ingress and
things like this bringing Pokemon into
it's something that people really liked
when they were kids and now can continue
playing this really new interesting way
I think that's really led to a lot of
the success it's just it's fun it's like
nostalgia and a lot as long it's really
cool like that's the social aspect of it
a lot of people are interacting with it
you hear stories both good and bad so
the good things or maybe we see people
walking a lot more you see people that
had trouble with social interaction
getting out and talking to others more
there's some indications already that
things like Fitbit the use of those
falls off over time we see that with
Pokemon go where it will be wow I gotta
go for another walk so I can get my
hatch my egg right and if Pokemon go can
really capture people's attention over
time and keep it then it could actually
be really powerful for you know getting
people out there whether that's for
exercise or social interaction so this
is one the first play of first instances
where you have location-based marketing
that can actually be very viable and so
a lot of stores whether they're here in
the states are over in Japan or the UK
are going to start to realize this is
one way that they can increase foot
traffic once they're inside now you have
to figure out how to capitalize on that
this game is one of the first AR games
out on the marketplace and it's draining
cell phone batteries one natural way of
perhaps keeping customers in the store
is just that having a charge up station
have a coffee or a bagel or whatnot and
then have them on their way there are
definitely people already going well how
can Pokemon go help with education
because kids like it they care how can
you take these mechanics in this idea
even if it's not poking among those
specifically just you know understand
what's making it work they're like kids
who've done pokemon tournament so they
know how
you know exact against each other and
the playing the card game version of it
and doing the decks so that level of
complexity mirrors almost anything you
tackle in school similar in a weird way
so how do you get them that inspired
that engaged and a lot of times it's
about relating to what they know and
what they care about and and so as
fascinating just think about let's start
connecting it to what matters to you and
that's I think always important in terms
of learning in general do you have any
ideas of the future of let's just say
the future of AR I think the future of
AR is it is great AR games are a way of
increasing that marketplace to more
casual gamers and getting everyone
involved in the game so do you think
this Pokemon Go app is a game changer
for entertainment I think that it's a
game changer in the sense that it's
gotten massively popular and so a lot of
people are now talking about augmented
reality and like laying games on the go
and this new style of gameplay so in
that sense I think it's a game